Easter Monday in the West Midlands
although it doesn't feel like it
the government will reassess the
lockdown on Thursday waiting for signal
to open up these streets numbers they
will be looking at crucially I imagine
not just the cases which are only a part
of the picture but the number in
hospital and essentially the number that
required critical care and they will be
looking at when those numbers start to
stabilize or indeed decline one thing's
almost certain the lockdown won't be
lifted all at once people currently
allowed out include workers and food
policing public transport construction
and of course healthcare so what comes
next public services like schools
businesses like garden centers age
groups like 18 to 30s this isn't just
about economics in this document from a
month back behavioral scientists warned
the government that if their quarantine
policy was seen as unfair then there
could be quote resistance and
non-compliance how do you pick and
choose between sectors and age groups
while also keeping everyone feeling like
we're all in this together
scientists say it's up to the
politicians ultimately these are
political decisions there's no formula
for which sectors which businesses which
parts of society must be or should be
released first I do think that political
decision makers ultimately they have to
take into account the best scientific
evidence and advice that they can get
they have to listen very carefully to
that but ultimately every country is
balancing different considerations this
politician said the lockdown wouldn't be
lifted soon this week sage will review
the evidence of the effectiveness of the
social distancing measures that we've
taken and we will consider their
evidence as that their assessment based
on the evidence at that point I should
say we don't expect to make any changes
to the measures currently in place at
that point and we won't until we're
confident
as a confidence we realistically candy
that any such changes can be safely made
truth is there probably won't ever be a
moment of total confidence it's a
judgment call one that will almost
inevitably involve telling some people
that through no fault of their own there
at the back of the queue Berlin menthol
Sky News